welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
without Tony Stark is understandably a
very difficult thing for many fans to
come to terms with the man invented
pretty much every gizmo and villain that
sat the course of MCU history like every
town is a fringe engineer who screams
with rage when ever Starks face shows up
on the TV when a character this
intricately linked to all corners of the
MCU dies one must wonder what secrets
were buried with him we have looked into
a few of the possible ways Starks death
could as it did in spider-man apart from
home leave some loose threads that lead
to some future conflict but there is one
mystery from Tony Stark's past that
Marvel definitely set up but never ever
delivered any explanation bored way back
in Iron Man 2 in an extended version of
a scene stark mentioned three old shield
operations that he wanted to research
tap the Oracle grid and ship stuff out
of storage everything from projects
Pegasus Exodus and Goliath now at the
time this seems like a bit of a
throwaway detail but over the years the
MCU started to define each of these
projects as real operations in its
history project Pegasus of course was
the shield operation that researched the
tesseract with Pegasus history going
back to the events of Captain Marvel as
a joint NASA and Air Force operation
with Wendy Lawson aka Marvel in the late
80s and project Goliath we learned in
ant-man the wasp was an old shield
operation with Hank Pym and Bill posture
Marvel Morpheus when I worked on
resizing technology back in the day I
was Hanks partner in a project called
Goliath so that leaves project Exodus
says the remaining mystery project for
Marvel's past yet to be revealed I must
have had some importance right and Tony
Stark knew of its existence so what was
it how could this secret government
operation blow the MCU wide open in the
near future I will explore this mystery
in this episode of let us begin by
pointing out that both Pegasus and
Goliath have two things in common
they're both terms with specific
meanings in Marvel lore but they're also
both terms with ancient mythological or
biblical origins Pegasus was the shield
operation in the Marvel Comics but also
the name of the winged horse of Greek
mythology also like the ones written by
Valkyrie and Valkyrie or Goliath was the
name of the giant sized Marvel hero but
also the giant warrior of the Old
Testament defeated by David in the case
of Exodus it was the second book of the
Old Testament documenting the departure
of the Hebrews from Egypt and
wondering journey to the Holy Land an
exodus more generally refers to any mass
departure of migrants from a region when
theory I've entertained before is that
the MCU Exodus could refer to these
Scrolls like we know from Captain Marvel
that Nick Fury and shield worked closely
with a small group of friendly Scrolls
that movie ended with carol danvers
leading these scroll refugees in a
search for a new homeworld away from the
Kree what she does sound a bit like an
exodus indeed and the post-credits scene
a far from home Nick Fury seemed to be
on a ship full of Scrolls fury could be
like Moses getting grouchy at all these
Scrolls get this ship moving but I don't
know why Tony Stark would need the files
from that kind of operation in this
moment in Iron Man 2 Tony was trying to
synthesize a new element to use as an
energy source for his arc reactor
project Pegasus would be a sensible
operational look into since it was all
about using the tesseract as an energy
source for weapons and Lightspeed
engines project Goliath would deal with
things like Pym particles and subatomic
quantum particles makes sense but a
shape-shifting extraterrestrial
relocation project not sure that helps
Tony here but then it is worth
considering that these three projects
were not in the theatrical version of
Iron Man 2 it was an alternate line of
dialogue from a deleted scene suggesting
that it was an alternate plan for the
MCU future that Kevin Feige might not
have wanted to pull the trigger on yet
and there was actually another alternate
scene from the early MCU with a similar
change made a recently leaked deleted
post-credits scene from Iron Man in
which Nick Fury reveals himself with an
alternate lights and assorted mutants
weren't enough I have to deal with a
spoiled brat who doesn't play well with
others and wants to keep all his toys to
himself assorted mutants and the phase
one Iron Man movies Feige originally
intended on laying the groundwork for
the mutants existing within the MCU and
yeah if you know your x-men comics
Exodus is actually the name of a mutant
villain so Exodus is a super powerful
omega-level mutant originally born in
the 12th century in France under the
name Ben they do petty he was given
psionic abilities by apocalypse he
teamed up with the Black Knight at the
time a kind of ageless superhero who
will be played by Kit Harington in the
upcoming Eternals film Exodus was later
awakened by magneto in the modern era
and joined the acolytes so in a meeting
context project Exodus could refer to
this mute
specifically or more broadly an exodus
of mutants carried out by the government
in secret as Siri suggested in his line
in the deleted version that seeing
mutants might already exist throughout
the MCU we just haven't met them yet in
the waste shield extracted scientists
from world war ii to the u.s. under
Operation Paperclip which Natasha told
Steve about with Arnim Zola and Winter
Soldier
perhaps shield could have extracted
mutants from their communities around
the world and relocated them to secure
places maybe island colonies for mutants
to live in peace and secrecy like
Genosha from the x-men comics or maybe
darker labs to exploit these mutants
abilities like a Weapon X program run by
Stryker we know from Winter Soldier that
shield / Hydra was aware of gifted
individuals who pose potential threats
around the world a list that they'd been
keeping for decades was target's this TV
anchor in Cairo an Undersecretary of
Defense Iowa City student could these
people be threats because of their known
mutant abilities now again Tony was
looking at project Exodus for details
about rare elements and as an energy
source he needed a new durable super
metal to keep him alive and there's one
material that still needs to be
introduced in the MCU the alloy known as
adamantium the metal that coats
Wolverine's skeleton informs his claws
until now the strongest metal we've
known about an MCU is vibranium but
whatever alloy Thanos his weapon was
made out of was certainly stronger than
caps vibranium shield I think the
implications seen that thing get
shattered is there's stronger metals out
there in this universe so when trying to
decode what Tony was referring to you by
project Exodus I think the evidence is
right there a hint of the existence of
mutants in the MCU the need of a
powerful new metal the implication of an
oppressed class of people needing to
extract themselves from society every
community named Exodus project Exodus
could be shield / hydras codename for
the cover-up of mutants in the MCU an
operation that we might better know as
Weapon Exodus it's a truth that we fail
to notice because it's a too much
what do you think project Exodus was and
what total conspiracy should I
investigate next comment down below with
your thoughts follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at ei vas and subscribed into
rock stars for breakdowns of everything
Marvel thank you for joining me and if
any word and Marvel has an X in it X is
probably marking the spot for Wolverine
[Music]